Sa femme s'est fait agresser en allant enseigner en maternelle.
Et ils s'inquiétaient pour la sécurité de leur jeune fille.
Que pouvaient-ils faire ?
S'enfuir ?
Demander l'asile dans un autre pays ?
Ils ne voulaient pas faire ça.
Ils voulaient juste vivre dans leur pays en sécurité.
Mais leurs choix étaient limités.
Alors ce mois-là,
Juan Carlos a installé sa famille dans un lieu plus sûr
et a rejoint un groupe de migrants pour un long et périlleux voyage
de l'Amérique centrale
à un emploi
qu'un membre de sa famille lui a trouvé aux États-Unis.
Nous savons tous ce qui les attendait
à la frontière américano-mexicaine
Les peines de plus en plus sévères infligées à ceux qui la traversent.
Les poursuites pénales pour passage illégal.
La détention inhumaine.
Et le plus terrible, la séparation des familles.
Je suis venu vous dire que non seulement ce traitement est injuste,
mais il est inutile.
Cette croyance que la seule façon de maintenir l'ordre
est de recourir à des méthodes inhumaines,
est erronée.
Et en fait, c'est tout le contraire.
Seul un système humain
peut rétablir l'ordre à la frontière.
Si on peut aller aux États-Unis
légalement, en sécurité et sans heurt,
très peu de gens choisissent de voyager dangereusement,
de façon chaotique ou illégale.
Je comprends que l'idée
que l'immigration légale puisse simplement résoudre la crise frontalière
puisse sembler un peu fantaisiste.
Mais il y a une bonne nouvelle :
nous l'avons déjà fait.
Je travaille sur l'immigration depuis des années au Cato Institute
et avec d'autres groupes de réflexion à Washington
et comme conseiller politique principal d'un membre républicain du Congrès,
à négocier une réforme bipartisane de l'immigration.
Et j'ai vu de mes propres yeux
comment l'Amérique a mis en place un système d'ordre humain
à la frontière du Mexique.
Ça s'appelle un programme de travailleurs invités.
Et il y a encore mieux.
Nous pouvons reproduire ce succès pour l'Amérique centrale.
Bien sûr, certaines personnes
devront encore demander l'asile à la frontière.
Mais il faut comprendre à quel point cela pourrait fonctionner
pour des immigrants comme Juan Carlos,
comprendre que jusqu'à récemment,
presque tous les immigrants arrêtés par la patrouille frontalière
étaient mexicains.
En 1986,
chaque agent de la patrouille frontalière a arrêté 510 Mexicains.
Bien plus qu'un par jour.
En 2019, ce nombre n'était plus que de huit.
Soit un tous les 43 jours.
C'est une diminution de 98 %.
Alors, où sont passés tous les Mexicains ?
Le changement le plus significatif
est que les États-Unis ont commencé à délivrer
des centaines de milliers de visas de travailleurs invités aux Mexicains,
afin qu'ils puissent venir légalement.
José Vásquez Cabrera a été
l'un des premiers travailleurs invités mexicains
à profiter de cette extension de visa.
Il a raconté au New York Times qu'avant son visa,
il avait fait de terrifiants passages de frontière illégaux,
bravant la chaleur mortelle et la traîtrise du terrain.
Une fois, un serpent
a tué un membre de son groupe.
Des milliers d'autres Mexicains n'ont pas non plus réussi,
morts de déshydratation dans le désert ou noyés dans le Rio Grande.
Des millions d'autres ont été poursuivis et arrêtés.
Les visas de travailleurs invités ont presque mis fin à ce chaos inhumain.
Comme l'a dit Vásquez Cabrera :
« Je n'ai plus à risquer ma vie
pour faire vivre ma famille.
Et quand je suis ici, je n'ai pas à vivre caché. »
Les visas de travailleurs invités ont réduit le nombre de passages illégaux
plus que le nombre de visas délivrés.
Jose Bacilio, un autre travailleur invité mexicain,
a expliqué pourquoi au Washington Post en avril.
Il a dit que, même s'il n'avait pas reçu de visa cette année,
il ne risquerait pas ses chances futures
en traversant illégalement.
Cela explique sans doute pourquoi,
de 1996 à 2019,
pour chaque travailleur invité admis légalement et venant du Mexique,
les arrestations de Mexicains traversant illégalement ont été divisées par deux.
Il est vrai que
les travailleurs invités mexicains font des boulots très durs.
Cueillette des fruits, nettoyage de crabes,
aménagement paysager par 40 degrés.
Et des opposants disent que les visas de travailleurs invités
ne sont pas humains
et que les travailleurs sont des esclaves maltraités.
Mais Vásquez Cabrera
pensait qu'un visa de travailleur invité était une libération.
Pas de l'esclavage.
Et comme la plupart des travailleurs invités,
il a choisi la voie légale
plutôt que l'illégale, plusieurs fois.
L'essor des visas de travailleurs invités pour les Mexicains
a été l'un des changements humains les plus importants
dans la politique d'immigration américaine.
Et ce changement humain
a imposé l'ordre au chaos.
Alors qu'en est-il des Centraméricains
comme Juan Carlos ?
Les Centraméricains ont reçu
seulement 3%
des visas de travailleurs invités délivrés en 2019,
alors que leur taux d'arrestations à la frontière
est passé à 74 %.
Le ratio de visas de travailleur invité délivrés par les États-Unis
à des Centraméricains
est de 1 pour 78 personnes
ayant franchi illégalement la frontière en 2019.
Donc, s'ils ne peuvent pas obtenir de papiers chez eux,
beaucoup prennent le risque,
traversant le Mexique
pour demander l'asile à la frontière
ou en passant illégalement,
même si, comme Juan Carlos, ils préfèrent venir travailler.
Les États-Unis peuvent faire mieux.
Ils doivent créer de nouveaux visas de travailleurs invités
spécifiquement pour les Centraméricains.
Cela encouragerait les entreprises américaines
à rechercher et à embaucher des Centraméricains,
à payer leurs vols vers les États-Unis,
et à les détourner de leur marche illégale et dangereuse vers le nord.
Les Centraméricains pourraient mener une vie prospère chez eux,
sans avoir à demander l'asile à la frontière
ou passer illégalement,
libérant ainsi un système dépassé.
Certains pourraient dire
que laisser les travailleurs aller et venir
ne fonctionnera jamais en Amérique centrale
où la violence est si forte.
Mais là encore, cela a fonctionné au Mexique,
alors que les meurtres au Mexique
ont plus que triplé ces dix dernières années,
jusqu'à un niveau supérieur au reste de l'Amérique centrale.
Et cela fonctionnerait pour Juan Carlos,
qui a déclaré que, malgré les menaces,
il ne veut vivre aux États-Unis que temporairement,
pour gagner de quoi faire vivre sa famille dans leur nouveau foyer.
Il a même suggéré
qu'un programme de travailleurs invités
serait l'une des meilleures façons d'aider les Honduriens comme lui.
Cintia, une Hondurienne de 29 ans,
mère célibataire de trois enfants,
semble être d'accord.
Elle a dit au Wall Street Journal qu'elle était venue pour un emploi
pour faire vivre ses enfants et sa mère.
Des enquêtes sur des Centraméricains traversant le Mexique,
par « El Colegio de la Frontera Norte » au Mexique,
confirment que Juan et Cintia sont la norme.
La plupart, pas tous, mais la plupart viennent pour travailler,
même si, comme les Rivera,
ils font face à de réelles menaces dans leur pays.
Dans quelle mesure
un emploi à bas salaire aiderait-il
un Hondurien, comme Juan ou Cintia ?
Les Honduriens comme eux gagnent autant
en un mois aux États-Unis
qu'en une année entière
en travaillant au Honduras.
Quelques années de travail aux États-Unis
peuvent propulser un Centraméricain dans la classe moyenne supérieure
où la sécurité est plus évidente.
Ce n'est pas l'envie de travailler qui manque aux Centraméricains.
Ni le désir de contribuer à l'économie américaine,
de contribuer à la vie des Américains.
Ce qui manque aux Centraméricains, c'est une alternative légale à l'asile.
Pouvoir le faire légalement.
Bien sûr, un nouveau programme de travailleurs invités
ne résoudra pas 100 %
de ce phénomène complexe.
De nombreux demandeurs d'asile viendront encore chercher la sécurité
à la frontière américaine.
Mais avec des flux réduits,
il nous est plus facile de les traiter humainement.
Mais au final,
aucune politique n'a prouvé qu'elle pouvait faire plus
pour créer un système d'immigration à la fois humain
et ordonné
que de laisser les travailleurs venir légalement.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)